Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Usloogullare. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistant Artistik.
Wir werden mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch beübreln.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ich bin damit einverstanden.
Ich möchte so als personische Daten erfahren. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Hermann Martin.
Ja, Hermann Martin. Könnten Sie Ihre Nachname bestabieren bitte?
Hermann wie Heinrich, Emil, Richard, Martha, Anton, Norbert, Norbert.
Nachname ist Hermann?
Nachname ist Martin.
Martin. Ja, Hermann Martin, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Da muss ich überlegen, wann bin ich genau geboren?
Kein Bild.
Nein, der 1. Februar 1960.
Ja, und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,75 m groß.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege momentan 78 kg.
Gut. Ja, Herr Martin, was führt Sie zu uns? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Also, erstens, ich habe in den letzten 8 Wochen ungefähr 20 kg Gewicht verloren.
Oh, ja.
Und seit ungefähr 2 Wochen habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Und ich habe mich heute Morgen selber in den Spiegel erschrocken.
Ich bin gelb angelaufen.
Ja.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben gesagt, wo die Bauchschmerzen sind.
Wo genau sind diese Schmerzen?
Ja, Bauchschmerzen, rechte Oberbauch, würde ich sagen.
Rechte Oberbauchschmerzen.
Und könnten Sie, oder, sich zu fallen, diese Schmerzen, irgendein Bauchschmerzen?
Nee, die strahlen nicht aus. Das ist genau da oben, wo ich es gesagt habe.
Okay. Und können Sie beschreiben, wie sich Schmerzen ein rückendes Schmerzen,
oder ein strechendes Schmerzen, wie können Sie beschreiben?
Also, das ist so ein Stechen des Schmerzes.
Ja, der ist immer da.
Immer da.
Und sind die Schmerzen grössig aufgetreten oder langsamer?
Also, ich kann mich jetzt nicht mehr genauer erinnern. Die waren plötzlich da,
und dann sind sie aber nicht weggegangen.
Ja, weggegangen. Aber immer da.
Immer da.
Und, ja, haben Sie ein volles Gefühl in diesem Bereich?
Gefühlen? Nee, völlig gefühlt habe ich nicht.
Und wie sich das Schildern, hätte ich jetzt gesagt, so 6 bis 7?
6 bis 7.
Und, hab ich nicht gemerkt, sind die Schmerzen immer schlimm, oder?
Nee, die sind ungefähr immer gleich.
Immer gleich.
Und, haben Sie Korea, diese Schmerzen oder diese Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, das habe ich vorher noch nie gehabt.
Und, Sie haben erwähnt, gelb, gelb haben Sie gesehen, gelb, gelb, gelb, wassarras?
Nee, das Urin, Urin ist eher so braun, dunkel.
Dunkel.
Aber meine Augen sind gelb und meine Haut ist sehr gelb.
Ja, verstanden, ja, ja.
Ja, verstanden, gut.
Gut, ja.
Augen gelb und Haut gelb.
Haben Sie Yukaris?
Nee, so richtig Yukaris habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Und, was denken Sie, gibt es ein bestimmter Einlöser für diese Beschwerde?
Haben Sie bemerkt etwas?
Nee, wie gesagt, ich weiß selber nicht, deswegen bin ich zu Ihnen gekommen.
Ja, ich habe noch gemerkt, ich verliere ein Gewicht, dann sind die Schmerzen plötzlich da gewesen.
Ja, sie.
Und dann war ich plötzlich gelb.
Haben Sie dafür eine Arzt oder beim Hausarzt gewesen?
Nee, ich bin direkt zu Ihnen gekommen.
Haben Sie dagegen eine Medikamente eingenommen?
Nee, Medikamente habe ich bisher keine genommen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Was meinen Sie, man mit Nachschweiß?
Schweiß ausbruch haben Sie in der Nacht?
Schweiß ausbruch, ja.
Der Kopf wird ein bisschen nass, meinen Sie das damit?
Ja, ich habe das gemeint.
Das ist aber kein Nachschweiß.
Nachschweiß bezeichnet man im Deutschen so viel, wenn das Bett nass wird oder die Kleidung gewechselt werden muss.
Nachschweiß, wenn der Kopf nass wird, ist das kein Nachschweiß.
Ja, ich weiß. Nachschweiß, ich habe gemeint.
Sie haben Gewicht verloren.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ich glaube, ich bin nicht gut, oder?
Momentan nicht gut.
Also seitdem ich gelb bin, habe ich keinen Appetit mehr.
Aber bis vor zwei, drei Tagen konnte ich gut essen.
Und obwohl ich gut gegessen habe, habe ich abgenommen.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Ne, Übelkeit und Erbrechen habe ich nicht gehabt.
Haben Sie Duschfarbe oder Verstopfung?
Weder noch.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlessen?
Wie meint ihr das so schnell?
Ohne dunkel Verfarbung, ja.
Schmerzen, brennen, nee.
Ne, gar nicht.
Okay, gut.
Haben Sie Ihre Hand sittern?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Hab ich ein Händezittern bemerkt?
Ja, Händezittern.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Tauchheizgefühl oder Creepen in der Hand, Hand, Hände oder in der Beine?
Haben Sie Ihre Bau, eine, ich habe gefrackt, kein Vergefühl?
Ne, kein Völlegefühl.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Gespiele in der Beine?
Meiner Meinung nach nicht, Sie können ja mal gucken.
Ja, ich würde gerne nach dem Aufsage-Sprech untersuchen.
Gut.
Haben Sie für eine Krankheit oder eine leichte, chronische Krankheit,
wie ich wissen sollte, z.B. Blutdruck?
So, Zuckerkrank bin ich nicht, aber mit dem Blutdruck habe ich ein bisschen Probleme.
Nehmen Sie dagegen Medikamente ein?
Ja, mein Hausarzt hatte mir vor ein paar Jahren mal Ramie-Pril aufgeschrieben gehabt.
Das scheint jetzt nicht mehr auszureichen und ich nehme noch Bisoprolol dazu ein.
Nehmen Sie beide, Ramie-Pril auch Bisoprolol?
Ja, beide.
Und ungefähr 6 Monate nehmen Sie?
Ne, schon länger, das dürften schon 2 Jahre sein.
2 Jahre, Ramie-Pril, viel Milligramm nehmen Sie?
Also Ramie-Pril nehme ich 2 Mal Bisoprolol und 2 Mal 2,5.
2 Mal, ok. Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein?
Entschuldigung, ja, ich nehme noch einen Cholesterinsenker, das Rathorvastatin.
Nehmen Sie Rathorvastatin einmal technisch?
Ja, vor dem Schlafengehen.
Ja, ich glaube, wenn ich Milligramm nehme, dann...
Das dürften, ich glaube, 10 Milligramm sein.
Nehmen Sie, ok. Und nehmen Sie, wenn ich andere Medikamente nehme?
Wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, was aber sehr selten ist, mal vielleicht so eine Paracetamol, aber mehr nicht.
Nein, nicht, ok.
Wurden Sie schon operiert?
Ne, bisher bin ich nicht operiert worden.
Nicht operiert.
Ich habe vergessen, haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber? Ich glaube nicht, ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich glaube, ich habe kein Waben, war es mir nicht.
Ich habe nicht verstanden, danke. Haben Sie Allergien?
Allergien, Sie meinen gegen Medikamente?
Medikamente oder gegen Lebensmittel und Verkrecklichkeit oder...
Medikamente, Allergien sind mir nicht bekannt und auf Lebensmittel wüsste ich jetzt auch nicht.
Oder Polen aller die hohe Schmutzung allergie?
Ja, in der Jugend hatte ich mal so gräser Allergie, das ist aber wieder weg.
Gut.
Raufen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche noch.
Wie viel Zigaret, wie viel Technisch rauchen Sie?
Und wie lange?
Das dürfte so eine Packung sein, auch ich rauche seit der Jugend, das dürfte vielleicht 30 Jahre sein.
90 Jahre.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, hin und wieder mal, vielleicht so in der Woche vielleicht 2-3 Mal.
Trinken Sie Bier oder Wein? Was trinken Sie?
Ich trinke eher Wein, Bier mag ich nicht.
Weil bis 3 Mal Wein in der Woche trinken Sie, okay.
Das ist eine Routinefrage, nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie schon Drogen probiert?
Nein, mit Drogen habe ich nichts.
Und wie gehen Sie Familien an die Alkohol?
Sind Ihre Eltern am Leben oder haben Sie chronische Krankheiten?
Also meine Eltern sind gestorben, die leben beide nicht mehr.
Aber chronische Krankheiten, meine Mutter hatte Diabetes und war ein Typ 2, so viel ich weiß.
Und mein Vater, der hatte Dickdarmkrebs gehabt.
Wie alt war Ihr Vater gestorben?
Mein Vater war damals, ich glaube, 75 gewesen.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Bei dir ist sie gesund.
Gut.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Söhne und eine Tochter.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, Gott sei Dank, denen fehlt nichts.
Sehr gut.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Busfahrer.
Waren Sie schon in der letzten Zeit in Ausland?
Nein, in Ausland war ich seit zwei Jahren nicht mehr seit der Pandemie.
wurden Sie vollständig gegen Corona geimpft?
Ja, ich bin geimpft und auch gebußt hat.
Sehr gut.
Ja, Herr Martin, ich habe für mich alle wichtigen Fragen gestern.
Möchten Sie etwas sagen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Geht diese gelbe Farbe weg?
Herr Martin, ich glaube, Sie haben eine Leberprobleme.
Die lebt aber»,
Ich sage. Aber so muss ich schon verlesst untersuchen und anders.
Das heißt, ich muss hier bleiben. Ich darf nicht nach Hause.
Ja, ich glaube, es ist besser. Es wäre gut, Sie können uns bleiben.
Sie haben, ja, sie waren sich die Augen am Gewicht verloren.
Wir mussten das abzuklären.
Okay, wenn es sein muss, dann ist es eben gut.
Ja, wir sollen Ihnen stationär auch nicht.
Gut, wenn Sie das so sagen, dann bleibe ich da.
Ja, vielen Dank. Vielen Dank, dass Sie Ihre Stolkliche antworten.
Manche hat jemand andere Fragen.
Also, weil sich nicht wie wichtig ist, aber vielleicht können wir auch den Stolkang tragen.
Hat sich eine Farbe verhändert?
Herr Stolkang, ja. Der ist ein bisschen heller geworden.
So sandig, würde ich sagen, Sandfarben.
War denn Sie schnallmüde?
Also bis heute eigentlich nicht. Ich habe mich immer topfit gefühlt.
Haben Sie ansteckende Krankheit wie Hepatit?
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Gibt es noch eine oder die schönen Anfragen?
Ich überlasse es euch.
Aber ich bin ein schwieriger Patient, das muss ich sagen.
Nein.
Das wird sich noch herausstellen, wir sind gespannt.
Sie haben gesagt, wir haben noch eine Schanke.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen.
Ich habe heute aufgenommen.
Ja, Herr Hermann Martin, der 62-jährige Patient,
er ist 1,75 Meter groß und 70 kg schwer.
Der Patient, der sich bei uns wegen seit 2 Wochen bestehlter aufgetreten hat
und die Stetsche in der Bauchschmerz, in der rechten Seite vor.
Und der Patient berichtete das, er in den Westen ab Wochen 20 kg verloren habe.
Und der Patient klart über gelbische Haut und gelbische Urin-Ausscheidung.
Nicht gelblich, brauner Urin.
Und der Patient kapand dass ihre Schmerzen plöstisch aufgetreten,
plöstisch und dauerhaft aufgetreten sein.
Und hier aufgetreten sein.
Auch der Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6,7 zu sehen.
Und der Patient, der die Frage nach anderen Zentrumen wurden verneint.
Und der Patient, der aufgetreten ist, sei unaufwendig.
Der Patient leide an arterielle Hypertonis, seit 2 Jahren.
Und auf Hypertokolesterinimi.
Der Patient nehme Regenmusik, gemiedelt 5,1 mg, 0,1 mg,
auch bis obrall 0,5 mg, 0,1 mg.
Und der Atorwachsitin, 7 mg, 0,1 mg.
Der Patient sei bisher noch nicht operiert worden.
Und er habe keine Allergie.
Er rauchte ein Fakkungssigaretenteknisch seit 30 Jahren.
Er trinkte 2-3 Mal in der Woche Wein und er nehme keine Drohung,
und er ist nicht verneint.
Sein Vater sei an Kolonkarsnung verstorben.
Auf seine Mutter habe Diabetes-Meditustipps geritten.
Und er habe eine gesunde Schwester und der Patient sei verheiratet.
Er hat eine gesunde Schwester und die Patient sei verheiratet.
Aufgrund der anamnestischen Angabe,
dort haben sie Hepatoseller,
Karcinom,
oder Chroniciacachwokum.
Machen wir doch mal Schritt für Schritt.
Wie gehen Sie denn?
Wir müssen ja nicht sofort, man sagt so eine Ferndiagnose.
Wir haben keine röntgenaukern.
Oder Chroniciacrankeit oder Lebesjerkönigte.
Aber ach, Bochum, ja.
Das kann ja alles möglich sein.
Er kann auch einen Steinleiden haben.
Oder er kann auch eine Pankretitis haben.
Wir wissen es nicht genau.
Aber haben Sie denn untersucht, sind die Schmerzen auslösbar?
Sind die reproduzierbar, sagt man?
Ich habe mal palpiert, draufgedrückt.
Wo sind denn die Schmerzen genau lokalisiert?
Über den Leber, Epigastrium, wo sind denn die Schmerzen?
Ich muss erst palpationisch unterdrehen.
Und ich werde auch ins Pechstion der Haut verfarben.
Und Palpation kann ich die Hepatomegale oder die Siphenomegale abtasten.
Auch abklopfen oder Perchition kann ich vermehrt oder vermehrt Atemgeräusche.
Dankeräusche, klar.
Wir haben sie untersucht und sie haben auch Blut abgenommen.
Wie sind denn seine Blutwerte?
Ich habe Blut abgenommen.
Auch Schüttewiese holen und Teilsuchung.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt haben sie Blut abgenommen.
Wenn jemand zu Ihnen mit einem Icterus kommt,
natürlich, Billerubin und hermolytische Parameter.
Ja, sehr gut.
Das muss man sicherlich mit angucken.
Habtoglobin ist da sehr wichtig.
Und die LDH müssen sich angucken.
Habtoglobin, LDH, Billerubin.
Natürlich, ich möchte, ich möchte,
Afafet, AFP bestimmen und die HGG so aussuchen.
Nein, das ist nicht korrekt.
Mit Tumormarka kann man kein Krebs feststellen.
Das ist nicht korrekt.
Aber Afafet, AFP bestimmen und bestimmen.
Ne, muss man nicht.
Noch nicht.
Das ist nicht richtig.
Sie haben jetzt Blut abgenommen.
Und dann sehen Sie, Elektrolyte sind okay.
Auch Kreatinien ist normal.
Harnsäure ist normal.
Aber der hat ein Billig gesamt von 6,4.
Und Transaminasen sind 2-3-fach erhöht.
Habtoglobin, 3-4-fach, je nachdem.
Habtoglobin ist normal.
Das ist nicht erniedrig.
Normaler.
Alkalische Phosphatase ist auch ein bisschen erhöht.
Der hat ein bisschen CRP.
Normaler wird bis 0,5.
Der hat ein CRP von 3-4.
Blutbild ist normal.
Der hat keine Leukozytose.
Hemoglobin ist bei 14.
Trombozyten sind bei 237.000.
Ist kolistärer Parameter erfüllt?
Ich habe die Bilder nicht ganz genau verstanden.
Was wurde nicht verstanden?
Sie haben gesagt, ich erinnere mich hier.
Ja, Bilirubin.
Bilirubin ist erhöht.
Eine Sache noch.
Es fällt auf, dass er eine LDH von 480 hat.
LDH ist erhöht.
Was ist jetzt der nächste Schritt?
Ja, ich habe die Bilder von 480.
Jetzt möchte ich ein Abdomenutra-Schaer durchführen.
Abdomen-Schaer.
Sehr gut.
Natürlich.
Und in Abdomenutra-Schaer können wir Galumbwege,
Galumblaze, auch Leber,
Pankreas untersuchen.
Oder Beurteilung.
Und wir können auch Galumbwege,
Verwigung oder Ödometriös.
Ja, es kann sein.
Klar.
Jetzt haben wir den Ruhl-Taschal gemacht.
Und Sie sehen, abdomen sonografisch,
keine Galumblasensteine.
Aber der DHC ist gestaut.
Ja, das ist der Fall.
Es fällt Ihnen auf,
dass die Maggenwand ziemlich dick erscheint.
Maggenwand.
Sie können mit dem Ultraschall ja auch den Pylorus-Bereich
einsehen.
Und das ist der Fall.
Das ist der Fall.
Wir können den Pylorus-Bereich einsehen.
Dann fällt Ihnen auf.
Der DHC ist gestaut.
Aber der Maggenwand ist ziemlich dick.
Die Pylorus-Bereich ist ziemlich verdickt.
Ich möchte auch
Enbus sonografisch?
Nein, Sie können ja erst mal eine Magenspiegelung machen.
eine Magenspiegelung. Jetzt haben sie den Patienten aufgeklärt und der ist
so Magenspiegelung und dann sagt der Gastroenterologe der endoskopiker, also
im Pülerusbereich da unten, Magenausgangbereich, da ist ein großer
Ulkus, irgendetwas Tumoröses. Er nimmt daraus Biopsin und sagt,
wir müssen noch eine ERCP machen. MRCP würde ich jetzt nicht machen, weil wir sehen ja, dass der einen
Stau hat. Ich brauche gar nicht noch eine MRCP. Dann kriegt der eine ERCP, eine endoskopische
Darstellung der Gallenwege. Ja, klar. Endoskopische Retrograde.
Sehr gut. Und er sieht, dass dabei der Doktors Coledokus von außen irgendwie abgedrückt wird, eine
Stenosa. Ja, die können gleichzeitig behandeln, eine Stentdorschung oder... Sehr gut. Ja, und dann
legt der endoskopiker gleich einen Stent dagein. Stentanlegen kann ich sagen. Stentanlegen. Man sagt
Stentlegen oder Stent implantieren, das kann man beides sagen. Ich sage, wenn zum Beispiel am Herzen,
nenne ich das implantieren, aber so in den Doktors Coledokus wird das da reingelegt. Ich sage,
das ist eine Stenteinlage. Gut. Und dann sagen Sie, gut, jetzt haben wir die Galle trainiert. Die Galle
kann jetzt abfließen. Nach der ERCP und nach der Stenteinlage sieht auch der endoskopische,
dass die Galle in den 12-Finnerdamen, in den Duo-Denum, alles sehr gut abfließt. Jetzt wird
der Patient wieder auf die Station geschickt. Was machen wir jetzt? Jetzt haben wir eine Probeergenommen.
Sehr gut. Jetzt sagen Sie mal ein paar Beispiele, was da oben rauskommen kann.
Welche Erkrankungen können sich jetzt da oben in dem Bereich bilden? Welche Beispiele?
Ja, Beispiel eine Colange, ja, als Differenziativ, das ist eine Colangeokarsinome, oder?
Ja, das kann zum Beispiel sein.
Ja, das kann auch ein Magenausgangskarsinome sein. Das kann auch ein Duo-Denum-Karsinome sein.
Ja, das kann auch ein Leber-Zell-Karsinome sein, was Sie auch gesagt haben. Aber ich habe diesen Patienten tatsächlich bei mir auf der Station gehabt.
Wissen Sie, was die Histologie ergeben hat?
Nee.
Ein Non-Hodgkin-Lymphom. Deswegen habe ich gesagt, ein schwieriger Patient.
Ungeregen.
Ja, also man muss dann alles denken. Deswegen ist es wichtig, dass Sie Schritt zu Schritt arbeiten und dass Sie auch die Ergebnisse abwarten.
Und dann kam raus, das ist ein aggressives, großzelliges Non-Hodgkin-Lymphom.
Wow. Interessant.
Interessant, ne?
Aber im Blutbild ist es unabhängig.
Das ist schön unabhängig.
Nee, das muss keine Leukocytose machen.
Gibt es keine Leukocytose?
Optomationografie?
Ja, das muss man nicht sehen. Wie gesagt, das Einzige, was man im Ultraschall gesehen hat, dass eben der DHC so gestaut war und dass eben da in dem Bereich, wo der Magenausgang da ist, dass da einfach die Wand verdickt ist.
Wahrscheinlich ist das so ein Lymphom, was so zwischen Magen, zwischen Gallengang und Leber in dem Bereich du denum da einfach gewachsen ist und das Ganze damit infiltriert hat.
Wenn ich jetzt weiß, das ist ein Non-Hodgkin-Lymphom. Was muss ich als nächstes machen?
Non-Hodgkin, wie können Chemotherapien fehlen?
Nee, noch nicht. Erstmal die Diagnostik, fast mal.
Bei Lymphomen müssen Sie gucken mit CT, ein Staging, sagt man ja.
Sie müssen jetzt gucken.
Ja, Abdomen mit Torax und Hals CT.
Jetzt sagt der Radiologe, das bekannte Lymphom im Oberbauch infiltriert. Do denum, Magenwand, Pankreas und auch teilweise die Leber.
Hallo?
Hallo.
Sie hören mich, weil Ihr Bild war eingefroren.
Jetzt besser, ich glaube.
Jetzt wird es besser.
Wie gesagt, der Radiologe sagt, das ist nur an dieser Stelle.
Sonst gibt es keine Lymphknochen.
Die Milz ist nicht vergrößert, die Leber ist nicht vergrößert.
Man sieht, dass der DHC ein bisschen gestaut ist, aber er sieht den Stent.
Sie sehen anhand der Blutwerte, dass die Qualistaseparameter zurückgehen.
Ja, das ist gut.
Jetzt kommt das, was Sie gesagt haben.
Was würden Sie jetzt bei diesen Menschen machen?
Natürlich sind Sie kein Hematologe, aber, was man wissen muss, non-Hodgkin-Lymphome, operiert man nicht.
Das wäre eine Fragenfrage.
Nicht operiert?
Nein, nicht operieren, das macht keinen Sinn.
Weil mit Chemotherapie können Sie diese Leute heilen.
Mit einer Operation würden Sie den Menschen einfach krank machen.
Sie würden alles rausschneiden, ist aber alles nicht notwendig, überflüssig.
Deshalb wurde dann der Patient zu uns in die Hematorhomkologie verlegt,
wo wir eigentlich Chemotherapie gemacht haben.
Chemo-Immuntherapie.
Ist das neue Immuntherapie?
Ja, das ist ein bewährtes Medikament, das Rituximab, der CD20 Antikörper,
das mit der klassischen Jobtherapie kombiniert wird.
Jobartizimab, die Jobplus Rituximab, oder?
Ja, richtig. Rituximab plus Job, genau so ist es.
Ja, und der hat jetzt mit der Therapie begonnen.
Und innerhalb von fünf, sechs Tagen war der Patient beschwerdefrei.
War sehr gut.
Das wird sehr schnell.
Durch die Tent, ja.
Nicht durch den Stent.
Durch die Chemo-Immuntherapie, ja.
Weil durch die Chemo-Immuntherapie schwilt der Tumor ab
und durch die Druckentlastung lässt auch der Schmerz nach.
Natürlich muss man diese Menschen auch ein PPI geben, Pantazol oder Omebrazol,
oder je nachdem, was zur Verfügung da steht.
Und worauf man auch noch achten muss, ja,
dass die Gefahr ist, wenn ein Lymphom die Magenwand infiltriert
und dann behandelt man ihn mit Chemo-therapie,
dann besteht die Gefahr, dass eine Perforation entspricht.
Ja, das ist immer die Gefahr dabei.
Perforationsrisiko.
Perforationsrisiko, weil die Magenwand infiltriert ist.
Und deswegen muss dieser Mensch etwas länger da bleiben,
falls er blutet, falls er ein akutes Abdomen entwickelt,
dass man dann chirurgisch gegebenenfalls intervenieren muss.
Es ist aber nicht der Fall gewesen.
Ja, das ging alles gut bei ihm.
Und die Symptomatik ging relativ rasch zurück.
Der war beschwerdefrei.
Und den haben wir dann so ungefähr nach 10 Tagen wieder entlassen.
Super. Er ist besser geworden.
Er ist absolut besser geworden.
Deswegen habe ich gesagt,
ein schwieriger Patient nicht so ganz einfach singen
und nicht direkt durch Symptome auf bestimmte Erkrankungen, Diagnose,
festlegen.
Das sollte man nicht machen.
Das muss man schritt für schritt gehen.
Und nur wenn der Prüfer sagt, was vermuten Sie denn,
welche Diagnose, dann können Sie aufzählen.
Aber nicht durch Iktorus oder durch Schmerzlokalisation
von einer bestimmten Erkrankung sprechen.
Das mögen die nicht so gerne.
Es könnte sein ein Leben oder die Garlin-Wegge-Probleme.
Ja, richtig.
Also das kann alles mögliche in dem Bereich sein.
Das kann auch eine Blase, Garlin-Gänge, das kann das Dodeenum sein.
Das kann aber auch Pankreas sein, wie ein Kollegen oder ein
Kollege geschrieben hat.
Das kann auch in dem Bereich ein Coulon-Problem sein.
Im Transversum-Bereich oder in der Flexura d'Extra,
kann ja sein.
Das wissen wir alles nicht.
Und wenn im CD jetzt gesagt worden wäre,
da wäre im Coulon noch irgendetwas,
was abgeklärt werden muss, hätte man vielleicht noch
eine OP machen müssen.
Aber so ist das Ganze relativ rasch und schnell gelaufen.
Man hat dann auch schnell die Diagnose gehabt
und dem Mann konnte gut geholfen werden.
Gut.
Ja?
Ja, danke.
Gut. Schwierig gewesen?
Ja, nur noch ein bisschen nach oben.
Ja, dann ist es schon schwer.
Aber viel...